is the brand new iphone 14 plus already
a flop well we have some bad news with
some reputable sources saying the apple
could stop production of this model much
earlier so let's get into it i will
share with you guys the number
statistics and findings and then give
you guys my honest opinion at apple's
september event there was one phone that
was missing it was not announced and of
course we expected it after years of
apple fans calling for a small iphone
with the latest features apple finally
gave it to us with the iphone 12 mini
but the results were not great because
not many people actually bought them in
fact it was only six percent of the
overall sales after it launched so they
actually cut down the production and
shifted over to the pro models the
biggest complaint was the battery life
and the 13 mini fixed that but the sales
were even worse so this year apple
changed over and gave us the 14 plus so
they switched from the mini phone that
nobody bought two a larger size budget
phone that people also asked for many
years but check this out the iphone 14
pro max dominates the first weekend of
pre-orders while the iphone 14 plus
disappoints
now this is from minxi quo which is a
long time very reliable analyst and he's
given us some figures to just how bad
the pre-orders are they are selling
worse than the iphone 13 mini
and the iphone s e3 which are both
phones that had terrible sales and
pre-orders he even said the apple
strategy fails this year and that the
sales are much lower than expected now
the crazy thing is at the same time we
have articles that are saying that lots
of people are willing to go into debt to
buy a new iphone this year this is crazy
20 of people think that not having the
new iphone is a sign of somebody
struggling financially and 31 think a
new iphone is a necessity and more than
the third say that that is their most
important belonging that is absolutely
insane so why in the world are people
not buying
this new
brand new size while having a nice lower
price well it's because of the pro max
of course
this thing is dominating sales and if
you take a look right now it takes over
a month if you order one right now to
get one now if we take a look at the
iphone 14 plus you could still order it
now five days later and get it
on launch day either shipped to your
house or go pick it up at the store now
i can understand why the regular 14 will
be available at launch because not much
has changed you know we have made some
new colors but the 14 plus gives you a
much larger display much larger battery
life the lighter weight in this size
because the aluminum and for only a
hundred dollars more compared to before
you spend way more money uh to get the
larger size and this thing is still
available that is crazy and because of
that quo is saying that apple may cut
orders as soon as november a month after
launch
if the sales don't improve on these
regular models and that the suppliers
are going to be suffering a declining of
revenue because of this really
lackluster demand and orders he also
shared some numbers with us with the 14
plus having the lowest order allocations
for pre-orders being less than 5
which is actually worse than the iphone
12 mini uh when that came out and people
waited years for that and the 14 pros
being at 85
so way more people are buying
the 14 pro max than ever before and this
budget option that seemed to be a great
idea shifting from the mini to a plus
size one
is not working out so well now in my own
video i talked about the differences the
benefits of the plus and who should buy
that and the benefits of the pro max
and even though there are benefits i
have to just say that the pro max offers
so many new and unique features such as
the dynamic island the super super
bright display twice as bright of course
it actually has a new processor camera
upgrades all of that
uh that it really doesn't make sense to
buy the plus if you care about having an
iphone and it is your most valuable
possession because that cost is gonna be
spread out over a number of years it's
not only an upfront 200 that you're
focusing on you got to kind of split it
up and see if it's worth it for you now
do i honestly think that the 14 plus is
going to fail well first off i don't
think they're gonna can it right away
even with the mini they didn't at least
keep it around a couple of years but
second i don't think that pre-orders
mean everything
just because somebody that goes online
and pre-orders right away doesn't mean
it's the whole market usually some
people that are more into tech that will
wait they'll wake up early like i do
they'll order
and then if you're into tech you're
probably going to buy the pro model if
you're not into tech which i heard that
was like about 90 of people that buy
phones they just go to a carrier or a
best buy and they'll pick it up there
well those are the people that are more
budget-minded so when they see a phone
that is the same size and they might not
care about you know extra cameras or
some other features but it's less
expensive they might be willing to pick
that up or even people that used to buy
the regular size and now that wait i can
for 100 bucks more get a much bigger
display it's easier to read i get a
better battery um yeah you know what
i'll drop that i'll drop the extra money
and i'll pick up the larger size where
in the past they wouldn't get the pro
max
so that is my opinion but you guys let
me know your thoughts now with that said
you guys see that we're in a different
set right here there's a different desk
right there so let me show it off to you
this is our sponsor ergier's height
adjustable electric standing desk now
i've wanted one of these for a while now
but first they were super expensive
ergiers is very inexpensive and not only
that you guys could see how stable it is
our pro mic right there
is picking up the sound the motor is
very quiet and even though it started
out almost as low as a coffee table as
you guys could see it gets very very
tall
while being quite stable at the same
time if you haven't tried a standing
desk it is so nice to be able to raise
it up stand up straighten out your back
it's good for you feels great and if you
want to chill you can lower it back down
their lifting mechanism has been tested
50 000 times and ergier uses a solid
steel frame with aerospace grade lifting
column connectors on the side you have a
control panel so you can fine tune the
perfect height and then you can create
custom presets so once it's set all you
do is press the button and it'll go down
to that perfect setting it also has a
smart anti-collision sensor so it can
detect any obstructions and they'll
actually rebound so it can avoid any
damage to your your monitor any
accessories and to the desk itself with
that it's created from solid wood and
they have three different finishes to
choose from it comes with dual cable
access holes to keep all your cables
tidy as it's adjusting because you need
the extra slack and i really appreciate
the headphone hooks on the sides it has
a high weight capacity so don't have to
worry if you're going to be putting up
multiple monitors and accessories and
with that you can actually choose the
size of your tabletop now another thing
is nice is that the setup is easy and it
takes roughly 30 minutes anybody could
do it so go ahead and check out our
gears solid and stable electronically
adjustable desk if you've been wanting
to get one this is a great deal i have
links down in the description for you
guys to check out also thank you for
watching this video on the iphone 14
plus let me know your thoughts about
this whole thing do you think that it's
not really worth it is that why that
many people are not wanting to buy one i
want to hear your guys's opinion for
those of you guys that did pick one up
uh let me know why you bought one
instead of spending the extra money on
the 14 pro max or if you contemplated
between them and you settled one way
also let me know we're excited to get
them out and compare them side by side
compare the displays the speakers and
other things that you don't really see
based on the specs online go ahead and
click that circle above to subscribe
check out one of those great videos
right over there listen max and i will
see you in the next video
[Music]